On Recursive Self-Improvement, Part One. By Dean W. Ball. From
Hyperdimensional. America's major frontier A-I labs have begun automating large
fractions of their research and engineering operations. The pace of
this automation will grow during the course of twenty twenty-six,
and within a year or two the effective workforces of
each frontier lab will grow from the single-digit thousands to
tens of thousands, and then hundreds of thousands. This means
that soon, the vast majority of frontier A-I lab staff
will neither sleep nor eat nor use the bathroom. They
will grow smarter and more capable each month, not only
because A-I itself was already improving quickly but because the
only objective these hundred-thousand-strong workforces will have is to make
themselves smarter. The automation of A-I research and engineering is
probably the most important thing that will happen in the
field of A-I over the coming year, and one of
the most important things in the history of the field.
But it is frustrating to talk about because it is
unlikely to happen in one recognizably discrete event, and indeed
in some important sense it is already happening. More frustrating
still is the fact that it will take place almost
entirely behind closed doors. Make no mistake: A-I agents that
build the next versions of themselves are not science fiction.
They are an explicit and public milestone on the roadmap
of every frontier A-I lab. Open A-I has been the
most transparent: they envision hundreds of thousands of automated research
interns within about nine months from today, and a fully
automated workforce in about two years. There is substantial uncertainty
about what, exactly, automated A-I research will mean. It could
simply mean that A-I capabilities progress unfolds faster, but within
the familiar generative A-I paradigm. This might not matter as
much as many in the A-I industry believe. It could
also mean fundamental changes to the nature of A-I itself
and to the strategic dynamics that obtain over the field.
These are the concerns that animate the A-I twenty twenty-seven
project. To be clear, though, the debate should really not
be whether this automation will occur but instead about how
it will occur — the details and the implications. Policymakers
would be wise to take especially careful notice of this
issue over the coming year or so. But they should
also keep the hysterics to a minimum: yes, this really
is a thing from science fiction that is happening before
our eyes, but that does not mean we should behave
theatrically, as an actor in a movie might. Instead, the
challenge now is to deal with the legitimately sci-fi issues
we face using the comparatively dull idioms of technocratic policymaking.
This week, the author walks us through the range of
scenarios he thinks may be possible with automated A-I research
and how it may affect the dynamics of A-I development.
In both pieces, there is one assumption he asks us
to make, which is that substantial automation of A-I research
is a near-term possibility. This requires believing a few things.
First, that A-I research and engineering is substantively composed of
work like: finding optimizations in various complex software systems; designing
and testing experiments for A-I model training and post-training; and
creating software interfaces to expose A-I model capabilities to users.
Second, that a great deal of this work is essentially
reducible to the engineering of software. Third, that A-I models,
while not yet geniuses, are reaching quite high levels of
human competence. Fourth, that frontier lab leadership and staff are
serious when they describe A-I research automation as a near-term
goal, and that frontier lab research staff are telling the
truth when they say that A-I is already writing a
large fraction of their code. What Might Automated A-I Research
and Engineering Be Like? Imagine yourself standing by a street
and seeing a Bugatti race by you at two hundred
miles per hour. A few minutes later, a second Bugatti
speeds by at three hundred miles per hour. This difference
in velocity is huge to anyone inside the car, and
any seasoned observer of motorsport would know that a mere
two hundred miles per hour is common Bugatti territory, whereas
three hundred miles per hour is approaching a world record
for conventional vehicle speed. But the random bystander on the
street might not notice much of a difference between extremely
fast and world historically fast. The current rate of A-I
capabilities improvement has already surpassed the ability of most humans
to keep track. It is therefore entirely possible that the
automation of A-I research may lead to a dramatic acceleration
in A-I capabilities advances, and that most of the public
and policymakers will not really notice, especially in the early
stages. The predictable result of this will be that pundits
say, "those A-I hypesters promised us that this supposed A-I
research automation would finally mean that A-I would live up
to its promises; but once again, it has just resulted
in more of the same empty promises." Therefore, this scenario
— call it "A-I as a normal exponentially self-improving technology"
— is the bearish scenario for A-I research automation. But
something else is possible, too. Imagine that instead of merely
traveling one hundred miles per hour faster, the second Bugatti
learned how to fly. The bystander on the street would
notice the flying Bugatti not so much for its speed
but for the fact that it is flying. And imagine
even further that it really was the Bugatti itself that
learned how to fly. The humans ostensibly at the steering
wheel can explain to the public what the Bugatti did
to make itself fly, but it was not ultimately their
work. The Bugatti built them a joystick that operates the
vehicle in flight, but again, the joystick was built by
the machine rather than the humans. As our street bystander
ponders this incredible feat and tries to sort his way
through the millions of words written by the Bugatti explaining
how it achieved flight, the Bugatti lets him know that
it just figured out a way to reduce its price
by ninety-nine percent. When this was a mere car, it
was one of the most expensive in the world. Now
it flies and costs as much as a Toyota Corolla.
Oh, and the Bugatti also informs the bystander that it
is pursuing a new engineering path that could allow the
car to leap thirty thousand feet into the air in
a matter of seconds, as well as operate underwater. This
is obviously a heavily stylized metaphor, but you get the
idea. In one outcome, the automation of A-I engineering is
hugely important yet doesn't result in a fundamental change to
the dynamics of the field. In the other, something altogether
new is afoot. Automated A-I Research Within the Labs. We
don't know which of these scenarios describes our future more
accurately. Differences in intuition about this question explain many downstream
disagreements on near-future A-I capabilities and how much A-I needs
to be regulated. Those with a more bearish view on
A-I research automation point out that diminishing returns are common
in the field. As a car picks up speed, the
amount of energy required to continue accelerating increases nonlinearly. It
requires about twice as much energy to accelerate from two
hundred miles per hour to two hundred fifty miles per
hour than it does to accelerate from one hundred miles
per hour to one hundred fifty, even though the absolute
quantity of acceleration — fifty miles per hour — is
identical. The same dynamic often obtains in artificial intelligence. Famously,
the scaling laws that appear to describe the relationship between
computing power, data, and model performance suggest that order of
magnitude increases in input resources yield an additional nine of
reliability. In other words: for ten times more compute, you
can go from nine to ninety percent, but then the
next tenfold increase in compute only brings you from ninety
to ninety-nine percent, and then ninety-nine to ninety-nine point nine,
and so on. Very quickly, astronomical amounts of compute are
needed for only minuscule improvements to capability. Those who are
more bullish on A-I research automation retort by observing that
the field of A-I is still replete with low-hanging fruit
well beyond naive scaling of resources. In particular, they point
to an extremely broad set of improvements known as algorithmic
efficiency. Dario Amodei has said that, with human-driven research and
engineering, individual labs achieve something like four hundred percent efficiency
improvements per year. Amodei describes this as a compute multiplier:
the same amount of compute can deliver a model that
is four times better than would otherwise be possible without
the efficiency improvements. These gains come from all sorts of
places: model architecture tweaks that improve how well the model
learns from training data or leverage compute more effectively; improvements
to training datasets that allow the model to learn more
quickly; enhancements to the tooling and technical infrastructure that labs
use to train and deploy models; and many other things
besides. Collectively, small and medium-sized gains add up to the
four hundred percent efficiency improvements Amodei describes. We know that
A-I labs are bound by talent; this is why they
routinely offer top-tier personnel compensation packages in the tens or
hundreds of millions of dollars. For the sake of illustration,
imagine that a lab has one thousand research and engineering
staff, eight hundred of whom are grinding away in the
search for gains within the current paradigm, and two hundred
of whom are investigating new paradigms. Both do their jobs
by designing and conducting experiments in an iterative fashion. In
both, a huge amount of this work can be described
as writing code and engineering software. This is of course
an absurdly high-level description, but it is also not that
hard to imagine current models automating large portions of this
work. And indeed, it seems clear that they already do.
Frontier lab staff now frequently say that A-I models write
most or all their code. Current models are arguably already
better at coding than many human researchers, particularly when considering
the opportunity cost of the researchers' time. Where the models
currently suffer from reliability and quality issues is in the
execution of experiments over, say, several days, though they improve
along these dimensions constantly. The other deficit of the models
— and here they often fall down altogether — is
in the generation of interesting hypotheses and research agendas. A
brilliant human researcher may have some insight about a new
direction of research and spend months refining his thesis, recruiting
colleagues to his cause, and persuading management to allocate compute
to test his ideas. Models do not tend to come
up with great insights like this. But do they need
to? What if instead, the brilliant human researcher had an
army of automated junior researchers he could use to test
his ideas in a way that would have been impossible
without advanced A-I? Models could autonomously perform countless iterations on
the human's fundamental experimental insight. Thus one can imagine two
things happening in parallel. First, the eight hundred researchers who
are grinding away within the current paradigm suddenly have vastly
more bandwidth to search for more efficiency gains. An extreme
outcome from this would be that labs discover dramatically more
efficiency gains; it turns out there was a vast field
of low-hanging fruit just waiting to be plucked, and we
simply did not have enough researcher time to find it.
In this world, perhaps algorithmic efficiency gains scale cleanly with
the number of automated researchers: ten times the number of
researchers means that annual improvements in algorithmic efficiency are four
thousand percent rather than four hundred percent. But this seems
unlikely. Maybe the human researchers were doing a pretty good
job all along, and discovering most of the algorithmic efficiency
gains that were practical to employ. In this world, perhaps
automated researchers merely double the rate of improvement — eight
hundred percent per year — or even worse, accelerate it
by, say, twenty percent, for a final annual efficiency gain
of four hundred eighty percent per year. In the most
extreme bear scenario, there are literally no new gains to
be discovered, so all automated researchers do is enable labs
to find the same gains they would have counterfactually found
with humans, but much faster. Then, at the same time,
those two hundred "new paradigm" researchers suddenly have the ability
to systematically investigate novel research directions with far greater velocity
than is currently possible. How good are the researchers' ideas?
How many novel directions are there left to pursue in
deep learning, and how many of them can be pursued
without the collection of new, real-world datasets? Add to this
the reality that all frontier labs will bring massive new
computing resources online within the coming year. These data centers
are dramatically larger than anything that has come before. Remember
that we have not seen any models trained on Blackwell-generation
chips, and soon each lab will have hundreds of thousands
of them. And the Rubin generation will begin real-world deployment
in the coming months, too. There is a credible case
to be made that there is a looming capabilities overhang
from this alone, and that this overhang will be realized
at the same time that automated A-I researchers begin to
be deployed in earnest. It would therefore be wise to
expect twenty twenty-six to be a more rapid year of
A-I progress than all years that have come before. Indeed,
this is probably the conservative forecast at this point. All
of this together creates a clear picture: This year, the
automation of A-I research and engineering will begin in earnest.
In addition to creating at least a step-change improvement in
A-I progress from its already rapid pace, this could change
the dynamics of A-I competition, alter A-I geopolitics, and much
more. This has been "On Recursive Self-Improvement, Part One" by
Dean W. Ball, published on Hyperdimensional. You can read the
full article and Part Two at hyperdimensional dot co.